je vous présente l'empereur
45 mètres de haut quatre mètres de
circonférence impressionnant n'est-ce
pas il a deux cent cinquante ans ça veut
dire que ce sapin est né avant la
révolution française
il a 35 ans lorsque beethoven composé
l'hymne à la joie sentant lors de
l'exposition universelle de paris
deux cents ans lors de la rédaction de
la déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme
il surplombe les 100 hectares d'une
forêt que je gère imaginez un instant
depuis que ça graines à germer
il a connu mille saisons 250 fois la
douceur printanière
puis la chaleur la sécheresse estivale
250 fois il a vu ses copains les êtres
perdre leurs feuilles puis la rigueur de
l'hiver le vent le froid la neige
en fait dans mon métier de gestionnaire
forestier
j'ai un rapport au temps un petit peu
différent de la plupart d'entre vous
quand je coupe un arbre qui a 200 ans je
visualise la trouée la clairière que
cela va créer les graines qui vont ainsi
germé poussé grandir et devenir des
arbres je visualise mon action à
l'échelle d'un arbre et du massif
forestier
mais surtout je suis amené à travailler
ma longueur de vue qu'est ce qui fait
que ces graines
une fois devenu arbres composeront la
forêt de demain
je prévois mes actions mais intervention
dans un plan de gestion un plan de vie
si vous préférez à 1 en 5 ans 30 ans 100
ans
mon horizon c'est le siècle qu'est ce
que cela m'apprend c'est tout d'abord
l'humilité l'honnêteté intellectuelle
je ne triche pas avec le temps je ne
peux pas tirer sur l'arbre pour qu'ils
poussent plus vite je dois composer avec
un existant de la nature et les
forestiers ont forgé au fil des siècles
avant moi mon action est de poursuivre
cette oeuvre pour les siècles à venir
tout en fournissant à l'homme le bois
dont il a besoin et ma responsabilité au
moment de faire mes choix et de
respecter l'histoire de chaque forêt
qu'est ce qui va lui être utile
qu'est-ce qui va galvaniser sa force
collective car une forêt c'est d'abord
une société c'est un arbre plus un arbre
plus un arbre
exactement comme les gouttes d'eau font
les grandes rivières les fleuves
puis les océans chaque arbre apporte ce
qu'il peut et prend ce dont il a besoin
ni plus ni moins l'immobilité des arbres
laisse croire qu'ils sont dans
l'inaction alors qu'ils sont dans
l'action permanente
ils tendent leurs feuilles leurs
branches leur sim vers la lumière à
chaque instant il capte le moindre faute
ont ils captent la moindre goutte d'eau
pour se développer et renforcer leurs
racines et leur trou
chaque arbre est utile à sa manière l'un
apporte de l'ombre à l'autre sa
protection contre le vent celui-ci ses
feuilles pour l'humus celui-là ses
racines pour aller capter l'eau en
profondeur tous produisent de l'oxygène
des polluent l'air purifient l'eau fixe
les sols réguler le climat produisent
des fruits du bois et participe à
l'équilibré de la forêt et du monde
chaque
apporte ce qu'il peut mais l'arbre ne
constitue pas la forêt il fait partie du
peuple le mans il apporte sa volonté son
élan vital dans mon quotidien
j'ai constaté que la force d'une forêt
et dans la symbiose une association à
intime et durable entre les individus
une communauté d'intérêts si vous
préférez j'ai pu voir comment les arbres
sont en synergie les petits êtres pouces
sous le couvert des vieux sapins et les
petits sapins pouces sous le couvert des
vieux être mais il existe aussi des
rapports de concurrence de compétition
dès le plus jeune âge pour finalement
trouver leur place de dominants ou de
dominer à l'âge adulte dans le
peuplement
puis ces rapports glisse vers des
phénomènes d'interactions de coopération
les dominants protège alors les dominer
les dominer assure la stabilité du
peuplement contre le vent moi ce que
j'ai pu constater c'est que la force
d'une forêt n'est pas dans l'uniformité
mais dans la diversité
alors avec un siècle pour horizon
quelles vont être mes actions pour
favoriser cette symbiose
ici j'ai fait une coupe et la lumière a
permis aux graines de germer ailleurs
j'ai fait une éclaircie il cela
renforcer le tronc des arbres
contre le vent ailleurs j'ai sélectionné
des arbres pour produire du bois de
charpente
cela peut paraître surprenant mais quand
on coupe un arbre ont fait croître le
potentiel global de la forêt à chaque
action j'ai choisi qui gardait qui fait
retomber
cela m'oblige à une prise de recul
importante dans mes décisions
je dois sans cesse affûté mon sens de
l'observation voir la forêt dans sa
globalité et apprendre son
fonctionnement la forêt mon école de vie
elle m'a aidé et m'aide à mieux
comprendre le monde et moi même aussi
parfois
moi j'y vois des itinéraires de vie
humaine
certaines graines ont poussé loin de
leurs parents
elles sont légères le vent les oiseaux
les ont importé loin elles sont frugal
se satisfont de peu de richesse dans le
sol pour se développer et créer un peu
d'ombré âge à leurs enfants et créer une
nouvelle communauté
d'autres graines plus lourdes tombe au
pied de leurs parents et pousse dans
leur giron protéger et en même temps
sous une tutelle qui les oblige à se
frayer un chemin entre les branches
parental pour aller retrouver la lumière
quand je vois la taille d'une graine et
qu'avec un peu de terre d'eau et de
lumière ça fait ça c'est magique c'est
fascinant
nous sommes comme ces graines nous avons
un potentiel de géant en nous et elle
nous montre qu'il faut peu pour faire de
grandes choses
un but capter la lumière et l'
enthousiasme d'aller plus loin plus haut
chaque jour pendant mille saisons alors
et moi quel est mon but
quel est mon plan de vie qu'est ce qui
fera que mes actions seront bénéfiques
aux autres à notre avenir et à celui de
nos enfants
pour moi la vie avant c'était trouver un
équilibre dans l'alternance entre
profiter et travailler deux éléments
pour moi opposé contraire profité s'est
brûlé la chandelle par les deux bouts
s'amuser la fureur de vivre
alors que travailler c'est fastidieux
c'est laborieux c'est pas très excitant
l'arbre m'a montré une troisième voie
construire je peux avoir un
épanouissement
je peux avoir un accomplissement dans la
construction même partielle d'une oeuvre
plus grande que moi et que je ne verrai
pas achevé
chaque jour je sais que mon action
m'apporte de l' enthousiasme parce
qu'elle s'inscrit dans quelque chose d'à
la fois naturel mais aussi d'immenses
aller voir les arbres laissez vous
porter par leur majesté
par ce sentiment d'éternité qu'il dégage
cette énergie calme et déterminé
regardez leur diversité et leur
complémentarité mois il vous comme
l'empereur et ses copains les êtres que
construisons nous quel est notre but
quel est notre plante vie en sorte avec
un siècle pour horizon
soyons des arbres ensemble soyons une
forêt merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]